im fußball muss
dies ist die geschichte von charles
boxster und seiner unbändigen lebenslust
trotz seines biblischen alters bricht
einmal mehr zu neuen ufern auf dr
charles eugster 93 jahre alt zahnarzt
und wettkampfsportler lässt sich ins
kugelstoßen und in den 100 meter lauf
einführen
das fazit der ersten trainingsstunde ist
durchzogen 3 schlicht um jetzt mit dem
atmen ja sie wird es okay wenn ich auf
rang sechs
ich habe mich nur nobis da an und der
museumsführer
[Musik]
für charles boxster gibt es nur eins den
sieg seine york darf goldmedaille sitzt
nur die eigene endlichkeit seine grenze
charles letzte jahre sind ein wettlauf
gegen die zeit
[Musik]
die oberfläche
ich treffe das oyster in seiner wohnung
am rand von zürich in seiner
altersklasse polster dutzende von
medaillen eingeheimst es weltmeister im
fitness zehnkampf und im rudern
[Musik]
geschenkt bekommt und zwar von der
österreichische sport verein in wien
weil ich da der erste person siebenter
nämlich mit lebensjahr an den world
masters regatta tag nach und so hat
alles angefangen 1919 ein jahr nach dem
ende des ersten weltkriegs kommt aus
höxter in london zur welt
dort lebt er zusammen mit seinen
schweizer eltern bis er 20 ist sein
vater möchte dass er arzt wird doch in
der englischen privatschule ist sein
lehrer not amused wenn man den herrn in
einen schwarzen tschador wells locker
und hat dank der macht und die hat dankt
ja ich bin geistig unfähig also über der
ganze menschliche körper kenntnis zu
sammeln aber die anzahl der zähne sind
beschränkt und vielleicht könnte ich das
irgendwie beherrschten
und so wird der zahnarzt und praktiziert
im zürcher seefeld bis er 75 ist seine
wohnung hat ring empire stil
ausgestattet
aus der zeit napoleons
[Musik]
dass ich so bewundernswert wenn ich nach
wie schwierig das ich damals heime
nämlich gold völliger gemacht und wie
schwierig das das war als als lochs
bohrer und denn eine entsprechende
goldstück herzustellen der haargenau
post
ich hasse derart kompliziert und hat
nämlich so viel fingerfertigkeit blut
und wenn ich das darf sehen was wir da
machen dass ich einfach für mich
umwerfend
drei mal pro woche besucht charles
eugster das fitnessstudio wie sie fit
[Musik]
tt.com das war 1986 für seine wettkämpfe
trainiert ihn silvia gattiker vierfache
schweizer meisterin im aerobic besser
sagt nicht zuletzt wegen des muskel
trainings sei heute gesünder denn je
dass so viele alte krank würden sei
völlig unnötig mit 24 hat der
tuberkulose später triebe regelmäßig
sport aber erst nach 60 begann ernsthaft
mit wettkämpfen noch einen
rückenschmerzen gehabt wenn man sehr
viele bewegungen macht im haus war
eingeschränkt weil die schmerzen gehabt
hat er hat probleme mit der schulter
gehabt eben dann an ressourcen wir die
bewegungsfreude in der schulter war
eigentlich gar nicht gegeben hat konnte
sich den oberkörper nicht trainieren
welche medien bekommen hat mit 89
war es wirklich nicht so dass wirklich
super aktion silvia gattiker fordert
sind 93 jährigen bis an seine grenzen
das sei kein problem wenn man langsam
darauf hinarbeite sagt sie
und wenn sie sich da war also ich ja
kochen wenn ich das mache weiß dass ich
wenn ich sage mein stunde lang auf dem
sofa sitzen dann wüsste ich nicht ob ich
fertig oder tot bin
da weiß ich dass sie lebendig wenn man
mit freude macht spaß da muss ich sagen
so spaß machen dass ich es neues labor
also lassen wir also dass da schon der
klinik kosten
[Musik]
charles eugster trainiert nicht nur für
sich selbst
er sieht sich als medium mit einer
botschaft deshalb inszeniert er sich mit
einer profi fotografen für eine kunst
aufnahme
wie gefallen dir meine schuhe
[Musik]
angelehnt an ein bild von manne das
einen skandal auslöste 1865 malte man
das gemälde olympia es zeigt eine junge
nackte sehr wahrscheinlich eine
prostituierte jetzt legt sich äußern
ihre stelle um mit dem bild des
nachrichten kreises zu provozieren
machen sie sich keine sorge dass da noch
die wilddogs aller vorsicht sei der
extreme folgen
ja also ich glaube dass mit mir
persönlich gar so besonders
aufreger waren dass 50 stimmen nur ich
dass ich das so was was ich versuche das
mache ich oft zurück dass sie realisiert
dass das alter eis für die schönste und
aufregendste und fantastische teil vom
land kassiert
und so legt das polster vor den augen
des reporters seinen bademantel ab und
posiert wie gott ihn geschaffen hat
um allen wird er sagen das geheimnis des
hohen alters ist die beschäftigung
james genießt das leben er treibt sport
er schreibt an einem buch er ernährt
sich mit viel gemüse und früchten ohne
aber päpstlich zu sein
[Musik]
seine beiden ehefrauen hat er um jahre
überlebt eine partnerin ist eigentlich
das einzige was ihm fehlt
und so lässt sich oyster von seiner
personal trainerin an einen
tanznachmittag fahren
vielleicht so hofft er findet er hier
eine freundin 70-jährige bitte die auch
sportbegeisterte attraktiv gute figur
lässt sich angezogen also es hat schon
sehr viel sehr viel ansprüche sind sehr
holen
die sache
[Musik]
und 6
allzu viel hoffnungen auf eine neue
liebe macht sich oyster nicht in seinem
auto sei es schwer jemanden zu finden
internet ist er auf einer dating
plattform angemeldet doch das angebot
sei dort bei etwa 70 zu ende
zum abschluss an die kommunen mitziehen
[Musik]
das zweite tanzpartnerin an diesem
nachmittag ist eine elegante
sizilianerin
der tanz mit ihr bis dann auch mittag zu
ende ist
dann übergibt er ihr seine visitenkarte
[Applaus]
später sagt bei mir es sei noch zu früh
um etwas über dem erfolg zu sagen
[Musik]
das karriere-aus wettkampfsportler
begann in england jedes jahr findet in
händler bei london die königliche ruder
regatta statt
von hier stammen die ältesten ruder
clubs der welt hier trifft sich die
englische upper class
charles besucht henley um die wettkämpfe
der klubs zu sehen in denen er selber
vor 75 jahren ruderte in einigen wochen
wird er selbst an den ruder
weltmeisterschaften in italien
teilnehmen
[Applaus]
charles sagt rudern aus klassischer
sport der englischen privatschulen sei
die wiege seines erfolgs hier war er
selbst berg schon gelernt
charles eugster ist in henley ein
medienstar
alle wollen wissen wie stark sich die
königliche regatta in den letzten 70
jahren verändert hat
[Musik]
unglaublich die ausrüster völlig anders
wir hatten ruder aus holz die einzeln
angefertigt worden
unsere boote waren aus holz alles war
ganz anders
[Musik]
es war 1938 als chance im team des 1
das war alte schule und ist es teilweise
heute noch
die gesamte atmosphäre die schöne frauen
die schöne hört wir sind immer noch da
und audi leicht von der ruderer diesen
einfach umwerfend
macht sie das nervös danke dass sie dann
vor augen wieder madrid das macht mir
sogar sehr nervös wenn ich sehe was
würden leicht daran braucht wird
intensiver trainieren
[Musik]
einen monat vor der ruder
weltmeisterschaft teil
sechs mal pro woche mehr als je zuvor
im 100 meter lauf und beim kugelstoßen
musste er wegen einer infektion eine
pause machen
das ist unterdessen 94 und immer noch
lockt das gold
der wettkampf ich eigentlich ziel zum
zweck wenn ich an einem wettkampf teil
denn durch erstens viel mehr als sonst
und zweitens krieges ein adrenalinschub
was für mein körper und von großer
bedeutung
und dann ist es soweit die world rowing
masters 2013 in varese charles eugster
ist für den vierer mit steuermann
gemeldet zusammen mit 3 82 jährigen
teamkollegen
noch 30 minuten bis zum start nerven
sind angespannt
die steuerung des buchs ist effekt
ich kann das boot nicht steuern
was hans ist für die gold medaille drin
aber ich drücke witzlos mannschaft ist
eine art versuchskaninchen für ihre
masterarbeit über gesundheit im alter
begleiter ziehen
wie lange kann chance das wettrennen
gegen die zeit noch gewinnen
die prognose ist dass sie mit 100 bis
heute es wäre das vertrauen das wäre
schön
wichtig ist eigentlich das über wochen
und das wissen dass es nicht ständig
bergauf gekommen
also das ist wirklich das wirklich so
stufen gibt
ich weiß nur eins frühen handel könne
fünf jahr verlust war aber wenn ich
fertig bin kann ich das nicht mehr
machen
die hinhalte nämlich eben fragt ja was
macht auf den 590 und ich weiß nicht ob
ich das
jetzt plane haben aber ich nehme einfach
wie bist du zur vor dem ersten rennen
ist die mangelhafte steuerung nur ein
problem
[Musik]
was sie machen sie nur wir lehren das
boot ich bin ein wenig nach fünf rennen
sechster insgesamt in vierer und im
achter
diese angst klasse bilden ob die tat
noch gewarnt sein motor lief es blinkt
dennoch nicht
dialog
die gesamtbilanz fünf goldmedaillen und
zweimal 1 sieg gegen ein jüngeres bot
trotz anfänglicher pannen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
juli fiel
[Musik]
[Applaus]